-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," guys.
It's time for a brand-new game.
This is "Can It Be Ballad-ed?"
-♪ Can It Be Ballad-ed? ♪
♪ Can It Be?
-And joining us tonight,
please welcome
the one, the only John Legend!
Oh, come on, now!
-Jimmy!
-Thank you for being here.
John, here's how it works. Okay?
I have a list of topics, okay,
that you've never seen.
-Okay. Yup.
-And I'm going to randomly
choose some of these,
and you'll have to
make up an entire song,
a full John Legend ballad,
with original lyrics
based on that topic.
I can try to help you out, but I
don't think you'll need my help.
-Okay.
-For the first one,
let's do Shamrock Shake.
-What is -- Is that, like,
a flavor of shake, right?
[ Laughter ]
That's, like, a special --
-It is for St. Patrick's Day.
McDonald's releases a mint --
It's, like, a mint --
It's a green, glowing shake.
And it's a milkshake,
but it's minty.
And it's green,
and it's pretty -- Yeah.
It's just -- It's like --
-Okay.
-It's like the McRib
of beverages.
-♪ I wanna do
the Shamrock Shake ♪
♪ It's something
that McDonald's makes ♪
♪ Oh, on St. Patrick's Day ♪
♪ On St. Patrick's Day ♪
♪ Ay-ay ♪
♪ Wanna do the Shamrock Shake ♪
♪ Ooh, it's something
that McDonald's makes ♪
♪ On St. Patrick's Day ♪
♪ I'm not even Irish ♪
-[ Laughs ]
-♪ But I want
the Shamrock Shake ♪
-Oh, my gosh! Come on, now!
-All right.
-You -- Wait until
you watch this back
'cause you'll be like, "I kind
of want that for my next album."
-Okay. I'm using it.
-You got to use it.
-Next album.
-Absolutely, man. All right.
How about "The Queen's Gambit"?
Have you seen that show?
Do you want me
to explain it to you?
-I know the show. I loved it.
-Okay.
So, it's chess playing,
drug taking.
Orphan. Janitor taught her
how to play chess.
Um, what else?
The red hair. Good fashion.
Bob. Bob.
What do you call that hair?
-Bob?
-She had a bob.
Maybe his name was Bob.
She had her redhead bob.
Checkmate.
-Ooh. Checkmate.
-Right? That's a good ender.
♪♪
Like, something...
-♪ Ooh, ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
♪ Who knew chess could be ♪
♪ So sexy? ♪
♪ So full of drugs and booze? ♪
♪ She said, "Checkmate" ♪
♪ And I said, "Yes, baby" ♪
♪ Ooh, checkmate ♪
-♪ Checkmate ♪
-♪ Ohh-ohh, checkmate ♪
-♪ Yes, baby ♪
-♪ Aahhh ♪
-♪ Ooh ♪
-♪ Yes, babe, yes, babe ♪
♪ Checkmate ♪
That was a little "meandery."
I'm working on it.
-No! No. No. It was fantastic.
You can't hear me, but I'm
singing on this side, too.
-Okay.
-I was doing kind of
a little stylistics.
I was going...
♪ Checkmate ♪
-♪ Checkmate ♪
♪ Yes, babe ♪
-[ Laughs ] Perfect.
-All right. Good.
That was -- Wait till -- That's
the new theme song for that.
-All right.
-Let's try one more here.
Let's do Zoom Happy Hour.
-♪ I'm on a Zoom ♪
♪ It means I'm not in the room ♪
♪ So is it even happy hour? ♪
♪ Is it even happy hour ♪
♪ Why do they call it happy? ♪
♪ When I'm on a Zoom ♪
♪ Ohh, I'm on a Zoom ♪
♪ It means I'm not in the room ♪
♪ So is it even happy hour ♪
♪ I'm not feeling happy now ♪
♪ I'm on a Zoom ♪
-♪ Zoom, Zoom ♪
♪ Zoom, Zoom ♪
-♪ I just wanna
touch people again ♪
[ Laughter ]
-That was called
"Zoom Happy Hour (I Just
Wanna Touch People Again)".
That is incredible.
My thanks to the one and only
John Legend.